the location the access to talent uh the
costs right trying to hire folks in you
know the valley today uh is is
relatively speaking insane and by the
way it doesn't necessarily get much
better locally here in tel aviv and
herzegovina so we've got to get creative
and that's again that's what we're here
to do
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel welcome to 20
minute leaders today i'm being joined by
jeff shapiro senior partner at kingsley
gate partners llc
over 25-year career in executive search
jeff has placed board directors c-level
and vp level executives for clients
across the u.s europe and israel for the
past 15 years he has focused on
partnering with a number of vc and
private equity investors across
high-tech and life sciences working with
israeli-founded early and mid-stage
companies to recruit senior talent
around the world jeff has a particular
specialty in software and infrastructure
digital health and medical device
companies
just shapiro welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you michael good to meet
you thank you so much for inviting me to
your offices here i'm really excited to
chat with you about executive search and
executive hiring but more critically
thinking about what does it mean to
onboard and help companies on board key
roles into their companies that really
are going to determine you know the
strategy of the company moving forward
it's not just engineers it's not just
you know the people that are working on
this is the people also that are they
need to think critically about how to
take this company and move it forward
before we get to that tell me a little
bit about your own journey how you got
to be here in tel aviv and be a part of
kingsley gates sure sure
uh so i've been in israel now for about
16 years i came here in the summer of
2005. i was working at the time for
a global headhunting firm based in new
york they were expanding globally we
were considering coming in aliyah uh
those two things converged and here i
was and so what started as a
a three-month trial turned into three
and a half years which of course ran
headlong into the mortgage crisis
mortgage crisis at the end of 2008 uh at
which point uh i left and i joined up
the long time friend of mine noam
eisenberg
and we built at the time what we thought
was going to be an interesting little
firm the two of us called eversearch
partners
our
pitch to the market was that israeli
startups early stage companies mid-stage
companies hire people globally
uh we were two americans living in
israel uh who i think have a decent
command of the hebrew language we
meet with companies on their own turf we
understand them culturally and we
basically said look as you guys go out
to the market as you hire senior
executives which is what we were trained
to do
somebody has to get out there and do it
on your behalf and we thought that we
would bring
a very particular uh almost a you know
the concept of the cultural nuances of
what make israeli high-tech companies so
great that we would be able to identify
those trades uh globally and so we did
and we we launched our firm we built it
little by little uh and after about 11
or so years uh king's leg partners which
is a roughly five six-year-old firm
uh we met up with them uh they were also
growing and uh we figured there was a uh
a convergence of our platforms and
something that we could do together and
so here we are okay so so we're talking
already about executive search doing it
on their behalf being on their turf but
also understanding the u.s market what
is it what is executive search really
executive search recruiting begins at
the bottom and it goes all the way to
the top and it includes ceos it includes
board directors it includes obviously
all the key positions
that record that report into the top of
the company um
what we do is identify
what are the key critical components
that a leadership team is looking for we
sometimes meet up with investors we
sometimes meet up with boards we
certainly meet up with ceos on a regular
basis but the idea here is that hiring a
vp who's responsible for building an
entire function especially for an early
stage company it isn't simply the
functional expertise that you're looking
for you're almost never recruiting
somebody who's looking for a job right
and the
process that it takes
not just to identify but to
get in touch with attract
and then shepherd through a process
that's what we do
now this idea of not finding they're not
looking for a job it's a very very
different process than having somebody
who might be an engineer or some other
or some other position in in the
high-tech force or in any industry where
they're at where they're happy to
actively go and interview and do a bunch
of exercises and and fight for the role
this is a little bit of a different
perspective right it's a different
ballgame yeah no i mean look at the end
of the day
most of the candidates that we end up
interacting with are not looking for
jobs
in today's market in particular and
there have been various markets like
this the early late 90s early 2000s the
mid 2000s leading up to the mortgage
crisis and certainly in the last few
years we're living at a time
where candidates are consistently
bombarded you see the billboards yeah up
and down the i alone today
advertising not just how great a company
is but come and work for us um and we're
living in an unprecedented moment where
attracting the best person isn't simply
about asking it's not even how much
money you raised from whom you raised it
how amazing your company might be
compared to the two or three other
companies that are competing in exactly
the same space who have a slightly
different version of what you do uh and
so the standard pitch of you know we've
raised a lot of money and you know we're
we're growing globally and we're we're
building you know at such a high rate
that pitch is happening multiple times a
day to the best candidates um i i would
say that ultimately we don't have enough
of the best candidates i
sadly or i should say i i consistently
hear from folks well i'm thinking of
starting my own company uh i beg them
not to uh
don't get me wrong i think we should
continue on the trajectory we're on we
have a lot of startups we're thin we're
thin on management and that's what
drives most companies out to the rest of
the world every company that launches
here launches globally on day one yes
and that headquarters might be in new
york it might be in the bay area
you know today companies are going to
colorado emilio just announced that
their us headquarters is going to be in
colorado i think it's a great move wow
um i think the the location the access
to talent uh the costs right trying to
hire folks in you know the valley today
uh is is relatively speaking insane and
by the way doesn't necessarily get much
better locally here in tel aviv and
herzegovia so we've got to get creative
and that's again that's what we're here
to do we're we're amongst
any number of firms out there who do
what we do we've made a business out of
understanding israeli companies right
and that's that in and of itself has its
own nuances how does the process
actually work because i think this is
sort of a black box that we see these
new appointments for ceos these are
people that are already have have
fantastic track records behind them do
they come in for an interview and do a
coding exercise do they sit in front of
the board and do it do a you know
passionate pitch how does it actually
work
executive recruiting in general is not
about interviewing i mean at some point
it is at some point there is a
discussion that does get down into
tell us about kind of how you built this
company or built that company how you
built this function or that function but
most of the time the executive
recruiting process is a conversation
it's us reaching out to somebody who is
gainfully employed not looking for
something to do and just to be clear
there are plenty of folks out there who
you catch them at just that right moment
yeah they are thinking about what they
want to do next and that's fantastic
but it's still a conversation it isn't
come and apply for this job it's we'd
like to talk to you uh about something
that will change both your life our
lives the life of our company
uh and that's what the conversation
really does have to be about it is very
much a personal discussion israeli
companies that we've you know as i've
come to learn over time
trust and
the idea of
of what brings people together
is probably first or at least on the
same level as the qualifications
obviously i want to find somebody that's
scaled the company from 10 million to
100 million right that's that's ideal
but the idea of how i how i bring my you
know my company together with that
individual and the fit that i'm looking
for and the trust that i'm trying to
gain and it doesn't usually happen on
day one and we'll do referencing
we'll do frontal reference and get back
to referencing and we'll we'll try to
understand this person the best that way
that we can
but ultimately speaking uh time will
only only time will tell right and
that's it's a really scary thing i'm i'm
imagining putting myself in a position
where i'm running this 50 person company
and where we have to now we have to now
hire our next executive our chief
marketing officer that is going to now
drive the strategy of our marketing for
the next few years it's a lot of
responsibility to bring somebody into
a culture that i helped build somebody
from the outside
is this it tends to be a simple process
right what what do i do as a ceo to help
mitigate the risks where the person that
are bringing will drive the right
strategy for the company
let's go back to your your other
question right the process yeah
we're not
we don't have some big dark words
somewhere right where we put the picture
of what we think this person looks like
in the middle of it start throwing darts
and hoping for the best
um there are different aspects of the
marketplace there is
placement right what we call assam on
this country where
you know i think there is a
there's a concept of maybe almost i'd
call it volume where you really want to
try to see as many possible people as
you can
uh in order to get a sense of the market
in order to to get different different
personalities and meet different people
um you know we happen to have a
particularly rigorous research process
right we spend a lot of time with
companies up front developing we we've
we've coined a term around it we call it
the synchronous fit process
but what we what we really try to do is
understand there's two
main
components to what makes for a great
hire it's the skills you know the
functional skills and we want to know
how how big have you scaled and
what kind of marketing have you done are
you a demand gen person are you full
stack are you a branding person we want
to know how many companies have you
worked with how successful have you been
that's on the skill side and then
there's the leadership attributes and
attributes are are very much the
softer skill the the leadership uh
components of what makes somebody more
than just a manager more than just you
know the one who's handling you know a
product marketing manager well how does
a product marketing manager grow up to a
director to a vp to being somebody much
bigger than that and that comes
from from developing leadership skills
and those skills include uh decision
making skills and and coaching skills
and
uh strategic skills and how to set a
strategy and how to execute that
strategy and so it's possible to
understand those leadership attributes
it's possible to interview for those
leadership attributes and again it's
less of a tell me about the time that
you were strategic we don't ask that
question yeah right but in the course of
a conversation the way you ask certain
questions when you understand how
somebody built something and and really
try to get from them
what their plans are what they how they
see themselves over the course of
several years
there there are trajectories that
leaders have
and so we look for those in in the early
stages of the process and then it's it's
a process it's a lot of talking it's a
lot of conversations it's a lot of
coffee
it's uh you know and it's and it's it's
less about come interview it's literally
come hang out with us so we can
understand this where does the kingsley
gate start and where does it end and i'm
trying to extrapolate a bigger idea of
where where does the firm come into play
here and where does the then the
leadership of the company you're working
with
take over the process and and the
partnership you know resolves
what how does this play out
look we're
when we kick off search and it's myself
and it's a team it's an associate it's
research it's our assistance
you know it is very much about hit the
ground running as quickly as you can
i think about searches as crime scenes
if you don't figure stuff out in the
first
24 48 you know 72 hours you're going to
find yourself in a problem much further
down the road
it's iterative we will spend a week
speaking to certain people and we'll
share profiles and talk to the client
we'll speak to the ceo and we'll get
feedback and we'll decide are we in the
right direction aren't we the right
direction at 40 days we actually audit
the process and we say okay if we
haven't closed the search at which to be
clear leadership searches generally tend
to take a little bit longer but we look
back at the process where have we been
where where's the next tranche of
research and what are we trying to do
and all along the way we're speaking
literally multiple times a week to the
client right and if you're not by the
way
we've got an issue right if you're not
hand in hand if it isn't a partnership
uh you know if there there is a
less
significantly lesser degree of success
yeah you know you know that a potential
search should have
um i think a hallmark of some of the
best searches are the ones where you've
got a demanding client somebody who's
there pretty much every day every other
day and wants to know what's next
um i think there's a healthy amount of
pressure that clients should put on a
search a healthy amount uh there is such
a thing as an unhealthy amount
i think that it's important to be
realistic about what the market
holds and what you're looking at what
time friends are we are we looking at is
this is this days it could potentially
be weeks and months
look in the old days
a good search
took 90 to 120 days wow roughly three or
four months three or four months
imagine that it takes how many people
that throughout that period would you
would be considered for this position
even
even just on paper
there's no rule for it it really depends
on on the role
um ceo searches are an entirely
different category than everything else
but for your average vp level search if
it's sales marketing engineering etc we
could speak to anywhere from 100 to 150
people wow i could probably end up
interviewing sitting down with 25 to 30
of those people after
after a phone screen after everything
else you would sit down on behalf of the
company first to see whether this could
actually be a good fit oh yeah we're
representing the company we're literally
we are interviewing the candidate we're
sitting down with them once the
candidate agrees to sit down
i think the idea is
that you know there is a certain level
of interest and by the way by no stretch
does that mean they get to the end of
the process
on their side or on our side um
candidates will sit down with us go home
think about it and say you know what
it's i've thought about it further it's
not quite right for me uh or i've sat
down with you and i've come to
understand the position better and it's
it's not quite what i think what i want
to do or you could decide to have the
company i don't we don't believe this is
going to be a good fit and so we're not
even we're not we're not going to
continue the process from our end
exactly so in other words it is it is
very much a there's that high level
process we we actually share you know
our thoughts and assessment of that
discussion with the clients and the
ideal scenario is you know we met this
individual you know they will have been
screened before we sit down with them
and the idea is we think this person
here's all the reasons why we think
they're good here's some of the
challenges the questions we've got you
should meet them so that we can figure
out if we want to move forward in an
ideal scenario a client should only be
meeting
five seven maximum ten candidates
throughout the process wow the idea is
it's it's it's a curation right right
you know if they're meeting 100 people
why do they need us yeah uh and so
that's in essence what executive
recruiting is truly about it is
providing a measure of management
consulting it's providing a measure of
assessment and taking everything we
learned in that first week or so of
discovery during the beginning of a
process and bringing it to bear on how
many people they should meet and and
that's honestly that's what i think
smart and let me rephrase that not so
much smart but i think that's what
engaged ceos who have any number of
things to do at any moment in time right
this should be the kind of thing that
you should offload because you can't do
it all right and so do you see any shift
in in executive search over even the
last two three years
or any expectation for a shift in the
next two three years because we're
seeing what's happening to the tech
scene not just in israel but in the
world in general and you're talking
about the demand and and how crazy the
market is is that is the operation
different is the vibe different
the truth of the matter is uh yes number
one um the sense of urgency has only
increased
i think we're living at a time where
um everything is moving at a
significantly faster pace i think at the
beginning of covid uh nobody truly knew
where we were headed with all of this
slowed down dramatically at the
beginning of covet if only for people to
figure out exactly what was happening
um once everybody understood that this
wasn't going away and that that
business would continue and the markets
would continue
uh i would suggest actually things
picked up pace um i think the idea of
not being able to nor necessarily having
the need to sit down face to face with
people uh accelerated things right our
ability to get onto a zoom uh on a
moment's notice you know where you can
go be on the phone with somebody and say
hey do you have time to sit down for a
zoom right now if we could just do this
face-to-face we can actually shave off
whole days to the process yeah uh and so
you've seen searches that might have
taken 90 to 120 days get closed in 60 to
80 days amazing um and let me be very
also by the way local searches searches
that are based in israel generally tend
to move faster than searches that are
based globally for i'd suggest obvious
reasons yep the markets the pools of
candidates are somewhat larger um i
think the time it takes to assess
somebody and determine that they're the
right person for you especially at a
distance especially over zoom right it
takes more time and granted locally you
know the distance between candidates you
know and and companies and the degrees
of separation obviously it's a much much
different scenario right i i love it
jeff thank you so much for coming here i
really appreciate it i have a few more
questions about you sure and not about
recruiting but about jeff and and i want
you to think about your childhood sure
you know before recruiting before
executive surge before making an aliyah
what really fascinates you as a kid
it's interesting to suggest that i
started my career as a kid
right i had a
close friend of our family was an
executive recruiter which
you know as i'd say as a child as a as a
teenager that literally meant just about
nothing
um the idea that there were people out
there who were tasked with
calling people up and saying hey do you
want a new job doesn't factor into i
want to be a fireman or a policeman or
an astronaut
and um one summer uh this individual
this family friend said hey what are you
doing this summer
i said i don't know thinking i'm gonna
work at summer camp i was going to go
get a job she said come work with me and
introduced me to what she did and
what was what was most interesting about
it and i don't want to make my whole
life about my job because it isn't um
but the concept of being able to talk to
people about just about anything yeah he
got on the phone with people and
engaged them in a discussion on almost
on their level right you know i remember
the first search we did it was for the
um
the chief librarian at christie's
auction house in new york city which
your granted you listen to that and
you're like i don't even realize that's
a search why didn't i just post that
online there wasn't one line right this
was the mid 90s there was there was no
the job postings were in the classifieds
and newspapers i'm still stuck on the
chief library this is the first time
i've heard about this granted you know
christie's auction house is what it is
and there's somebody out there whose
responsibility it is to catalog
everything to ensure everything is what
it is but i get on the phone with folks
and i represent myself as a recruiter
and i say hey what are you doing tell me
about your life and all of a sudden i'm
having a discussion with people about
you know what they want to be doing um
what their aspirations are
uh and so you know it's a long-winded
answer to your question but i i love the
idea of people sharing with me and me
being able to kind of engage them and
it's a function of empathy i think i
think it the idea of helping people kind
of figure out certain aspects of what
they want to do that was to me
amazing you know um
beyond that you know i was a musician
growing up so the idea of what i could
do with that i had a band you know we
used to we do all kinds of things you
know but i liked being out there i liked
i liked being in front of the crowd very
very cool and what inspires it today
it's cliche but
i love the idea of building big
companies i i think you know the
executive recruiting experience is very
individual
um but there's nothing better than doing
that first search which leads to that
second search which leads to that third
or fourth search where you bring people
in who have a
an amazing material impact on taking
companies from zero to five to ten
million you watch engaging by the way
some some particularly big personalities
i had an opportunity once to recruit a
board member uh who ultimately became
cfo of a
200 billion dollar company
he wasn't the cfo of that 200 billion
dollar company when i met him but
interacting at that level with those
types of people it's it's pretty
impressive
in order three words to describe
yourself
wow
easiest question of them all i need a
sip um
curious
empathetic
i'm a good listener
i
truly enjoy hearing people's stories if
i can be helpful i will
um if i can't i'll tell you and you know
i i do my best to leave every discussion
leaving people and the conversation
itself better often when i started
jeff thank you very very much this is
great michael it's really good to meet
you